you know I grew up with dr. Seuss books
in fact I have a stack of them in my
closet right now that I could bring out
you'd be pretty embarrassing I'm not
going to I'm lazy there are two stories
in The Lorax that are kind of going back
and forth with one another the one story
that we start out with is this boy who
lives in this town and the town is
overrun with plastic there's no real
trees there's all the transportation is
fake that's just nothing but technology
there's no nature anymore it's this ugly
place overrun by this crazy weird guy
who looks like the woman from
Incredibles and as you know without
trees there's no oxygen so he has made
money selling air to people he wants to
keep it that way because he's an evil
corporate guy who hates nature but this
little boy likes a girl in town and she
is just dreaming of a time where they
used to be trees she kind of quickly
blurts out that if a boy ever gave her a
tree she'd marry him on the spot so he
sets out to try to find one tree to
bring to her and he runs into this guy
called the once-ler who tells him this
story about this place where it used to
be trees he learns the whole backstory
of this place how all the trees went
away how the evil guy who wants to sell
air is just continuing to profit off of
absolutely nothing it's actually really
hard to describe that plot I thought the
larks was an OK film I've seen better
family films my favorite part of this
movie by far was definitely Danny
DeVito's voice work he was so good as
the Lorax
I wanted more of the Lorax I didn't get
enough of the Lorax surprisingly he
wasn't really in the movie that much I
was a little bit disappointed I wanted
more of his character he was funny and I
loved his voice work and he wasn't
annoying or anything I just really liked
his character a problem I did definitely
have in the movie though is I thought
they were too way too much dance numbers
singing and everything I've said this
before in videos I'm not a huge fan of
when characters suddenly break out into
song for some movies it works The Lion
King is just that that's like the
perfect combination of songs plus
they're really well-written and funny
and in this movie I could really only
pick out one song that seemed like it
was anything other than like a standard
Radio Disney song another issue I had at
the movie was the stories there are two
stories and because of that it seemed
like the movie didn't even have a
central character you start out thinking
the boys the main character then you
learn about this one's their guy in his
past and then he becomes the main
character then the Lorax comes in and
you're a little bit focused on him and
then it goes back between these two
stories and I couldn't really latched
onto one main character in the movie
a little bit of a hard time liking some
of the characters because a lot of them
just weren't really that different I
didn't really find the characters that
likeable except for the Lorax
and I wanted more of the Lorax the movie
has a very good message but at times it
really felt like it was an environmental
film like trying to just persuade adults
and young children to stop cutting down
trees and plant trees and the you know
A+ environment which is a great message
but at times it kind of lost the
adventurous feel of a family film and
got a little bit too preachy and that
did bug me a little bit
however the animation for the film is
very colorful the character of the Lorax
was fun there were some good sequences
in the movie but for the most part I
just thought it was an OK family film
for me the movie was pretty forgettable
but it's not a terrible film at all I
think kids will enjoy it it's a good
movie for families to see together and
does have a good message so I'm going to
give the Lorax a b-minus if you can
think of it what do you think your
favorite movie is that involves people
to just break out in a song because I do
have a hard time dealing with that
but I know there were some really good
ones out there with some classics like
Sound of Music but mine probably is the
Lion King if you liked this review you
can subscribe to my channel and get
stuck mine eyes